hey Adrian how's it going bro how's it
going bro good how you doing good good
all right so why don't you tell us a bit
about your story is Christian pretty
much my whole life after going to church
around 18. a few years ago I had a
friend who converted to Islam I always
asked him about it like I always would
just check like hey are you still I
would ask him are you do you still
practice Islam and he'd always tell me
yes it just caught my mind and it really
interested me in late 2022 I gotten into
some issues and
I just found myself on a uh
on a nap praying to God screaming for
for God's help and
I noticed that in Islam there's also
similar like different prayer mats and
it just kind of it shocked me and so I
ended up buying a Quran
um wow just became more interested in
the three Muslims Channel and yeah
I was expecting to go on stream today
sorry
no worries that's that's a very
beautiful story so with that being said
no point in delaying it let me share my
screen
uh so have you seen a shahada before do
you know how it goes
I've seen seen it on your stream but um
I know it's I haven't gone through one
before no okay all right so and that's
all that's all that matters if you've
seen it before we're gonna go through it
together so first I'm just gonna ask you
six very simple questions just to make
sure that you have the basic academic
beliefs in line before you accept Islam
so firstly do you believe that there's
only one God worthy of worship with no
Partners no Sons no daughters no
Associates I do perfect and do you
believe in the angels that God describes
in the Quran I do and do you believe in
the prophets and The Messengers that God
has sent to the world like you know
Abraham and Moses and Jesus and the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him yes
perfect and do you believe in the
Revelation that Allah has sent with
these prophets like the Quran the
original gospel the original Torah and
so on and so forth
I do yes perfect
and do you believe in
um destiny and decree from God
yes and lastly do you believe in life
after death in the day of judgment
I do okay perfect so now you're just
gonna repeat after me in Arabic and I
have the words on the screen here for
you okay can you see the screen
I can okay perfect so say Ash hadu
and LA
Allah
Anna Anna muhammadan muhammadan
rasulu
perfect now you're just gonna repeat
after me in English
say I bear witness I bear witness that
there's none worthy of worship that
there is none worthy of worship except
for Allah except for Allah and I bear
witness and I bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the Prophet
Muhammad
is the servant is the servant and
messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah
so that's that's how easy it is to
become Muslim you are officially our
brother in Islam now alhamdulillah thank
you of course
um how do you feel bro how do you feel
so great
um
I think it's been a long time coming
um I kind of
have been putting off on just because
I've felt like there's so much that I
need to know and there's so much that I
need to learn that
um
I almost don't feel like I don't know I
didn't feel like I was even qualified to
do a shahada but
um
I won't let me learn about this religion
and uh just feeling my feet wet and is
the first step so yeah alhamdulillah
sister Flavia what advice would you have
for brother Adrian because I'm sure at
one point you felt like this is taking
on a lot you know did I do it
prematurely am I ready to be a Muslim
because once you do the shahada you kind
of it's It's it you know yeah yeah
um brother Adrian just like say
I'm the lion Muslim now all your sins
are forgiven everything from the past is
in the past but my
my advice to you is to take stuff slowly
okay don't burden yourself with a lot of
things at once because you will find
yourself getting overwhelmed right and I
a lot of people say this and um it's
true right I even feel overwhelmed
sometimes with the amount of information
that people give me and I've been three
years a Muslim right and I still feel
that today
and I could tell you that even born
Muslims feel that way sometimes as well
so take your time
study the dean study you're you're going
to get more knowledgeable with time
and inshallah like you have a
you have a good road straight path thank
you
and um we're definitely gonna connect
afterwards now that you and fight have
exchanged emails and Shout out we can
grab your number we can make a group
chat and we actually have um the three
Muslims Discord I don't know if you've
joined it or not but you can do that I
actually have dedicated Brothers in
there
um who will answer any question you have
and help you with it and also you know
provide a community because one thing
we're really big on in Islam and I think
Muslims really really need to work
um that was not a funny joke by the way
oh yeah literally something that Muslims
really I think need to work on is
building a good Community for reviews
like yourself so that's something that
we're looking to do so I'll send you the
links to the Discord you can join in
we're going to take good care of it I
mentioned you are a brother in Islam it
might seem a bit scary now but I promise
you it's it's really not that difficult
you know the prophet peace be upon him
um a man came to him once and he said
you know what what should I do for Islam
and the prophet saw him he told him you
believe none worthy of worship except
Allah in the prophet Muhammad as the
last messenger of Allah that's the
shahada you just gave that's the
testimony right you just testified to
secondly is that you pray five times a
day and I know someone who doesn't pray
five times a day hearing that is like oh
that's difficult but imagine I said five
different points in the day you're gonna
sit down for two three minutes and
you're gonna meditate that wouldn't be
something that's difficult really and I
know you've probably seen how Muslims
pray it's very it's kind of like
recharging your battery throughout the
day you got to disconnect you say Allah
God is greater than everything else
right that's what Allahu Akbar means God
is greater than the work in school and
you know family stresses and whatever
and you get to focus on you your
connection with him and pray so you know
the first and the second thing just the
shahada I praying five times a day
um fasting the month of Ramadan
uh giving two and a half percent of your
you know your savings in charity to help
the poor and if you can once in your
lifetime if you can physically and
financially afford it you go to uh Mecca
and you do what is called hygiene I can
tell you about that um but it's a very
beautifully spiritually enlightening
Journey so back to the Hadith the
prophet said these five things to me
just five things
you know throughout your life
and the man said I'm only going to do
that and nothing else
and the prophet beats upon him he said
if he if he's straight stays true to
that if he actually does those five
things consistently and he doesn't do
like excessive evil then he will go to
Jannah that is what the prophet peace be
upon him told you know us in the Hadith
as well so it might seem like it's a lot
now and even maybe the five things I
read off you're like oh how am I gonna
do this and that I promise once the time
comes and you've been doing it like for
a few days or for a year even fasting
you know after five six days your body
gets used to it it will be very
beneficial and it will it will not be
difficult for you inshallah
so Rami just real quick with this is
what people are commenting
what the heck and someone wrote It's
because you need to set it to stay
active forever the setting just like
maybe maybe sister flavi knows more
about this course yeah you're a gamer
yeah you need to activate it okay um
brother Adrian I saw that your Quran
says in Spanish oh English I think it
was just oh English I thought it was
Spanish
look at that
so brother Adrian do you have any last
minute questions for us even though we
don't want to overwhelm you but maybe
there's something on your mind right now
that you were hesitant asking do you you
can take the time now
um I think I might just try and go
through the Discord
um
see about any mosques in the community I
found one nearby
um I'm not really sure how the the hours
work or if it's a similar
um I guess I can look online to check
that out but
um right now I'm good you guys have my
email YouTube I think uh blocking it
when I was trying to send it yeah
because
um I had to like yeah I sent it
um but Mila bless you bro you're gonna
be in our duas everyone make Dua for
Adrian tonight whatever time zone you're
in that he stays steadfast in the dean
inshallah man that he stays on the right
path I mean I mean
all right